welcome back with Tommy Fury will fight
Jake Paul and Saudi Arabia later this
month one is a boxer the other is a
YouTuber so what's it all about
let's have a look
I'm really excited that Tommy loses he
can stay in Saudi Arabia
he can become Cristiano Ronaldo's best
panel and he become a PT for Ronaldo in
Saudi
well Tommy Fury joins me now you're
going to become the Cristiano Ronaldo of
boxing in Saudi apparently no bad thing
to be my mate in Saudi the highest paid
athlete in the world at 37.
yeah definitely I mean there's a reason
he's gone outside isn't he but uh best
thoughts Cristiano Ronaldo in uh in his
move out there hope he plays even better
football out there
it's a very interesting debate about
these YouTubers turn boxes about whether
they're making a mockery of the great
sport of boxing you're a boxer and
always have been but what do you make of
it I mean are they at a level now these
Paul brothers were actually that
argument no longer carries water
I mean at the end of the day um in my
opinion it's bringing new eyes to boxing
and that's the only positive thing I can
say about it really
um other than that it is what it is you
they're not proper professional boxers
you know they're just people who's
playing at it you know doing it to
entertain the crowd and a few quiz and
that's it really but when you put one of
those in with a professional boxer well
you're all about to see what's going to
happen but I don't know it's bringing
new eyes to the sport you know kids are
getting involved that wouldn't normally
watch it so yeah it's great what if you
lose I mean Tyson's already made it
clear what his reaction will be which is
basically disowning you by the sound of
it but for you to to lose to someone
who's not even a real boxer that would
be Unthinkable right
of course and that's why that's not an
option there is no way that this man
could beat me even if you had a hammer
in both hands I gotta say that way and
I'm going to exhibit that yeah I've made
it two rules in life never fight anyone
called Tyson or Fury
just seems to me to be a active cell
phone
well soon it's going to be never fight
anyone called Tyson and never fight
anyone called Tommy because I'm going to
prove that under four weeks out of
interest if you had a fight ever had a
fight with uh with Tyson
I've had many fights with Tyson in the
gym yes but I can't reach his head so
I'll just take his hips that's where I'm
online with have you ever knocked each
other out
uh no I mean at the end of the day if I
steal his breakfast he might eat with a
few good right hands and wobble me up a
bit but that's not happened so far I'm a
bit more wiser than that now more
personally last time I interviewed uh
Tyson he was on this show and I he said
he was retiring and I said I don't
believe you and in fact if you do come
back in the ring professionally you've
got to give me a million pounds will you
take the BET and he took it live on air
and then said on talksport he would pay
me in pound coins can you just tell him
I'm still waiting and every morning I
run down to the the post office there's
no bag of coins Tommy
well I'm sorry Pierce but I hate to say
I haven't got the stones to go up to and
ask for your million pound you have to
do that yourself
I'll bring it but I'm not scared I'll
ring him um what's going to happen in
this fight you think you're gonna knock
him out
I know I'm gonna knock him out this
fight will not go any more than four
rounds and the stuff that I'm doing in
the gym the people that I'm handling in
the gym there's no way this goes the
distance
and he apparently uh went on social
media to reveal that you'd become a
father without you guys even getting the
chance you and Molly may your partner to
say it yourself
listen at the end of the day all Jake
Paul can do from you know wherever he is
in this world is speculate and that's
all that was speculation and you know
nothing's ever true unless you hear it
from me and Molly
do you like the trash talking side of
boxing
it's part of the parcel you know it is
what it is it's stuff that we have to do
it's um it's called the you know the
entertainment business that's the game
that we're in and me and me and Jake
Paul are great dance Partners
um and I've enjoyed the build up so far
it's going to get a lot more heated and
I can't wait but the real work starts
when we get inside them ropes and social
media can't save Jake Paul his mouth
can't save him it comes down to fighting
and I'm a lot better at doing that than
him
and just in case things don't go right
do you want me to text Cristiano tonight
and just see if he's got any spare rooms
I mean if he's uh yeah I mean why not
Saudi I mean I could come accustomed for
living out there but peers you're going
to see pigs flying there before someone
goes wrong with me and Jake Paul I'll
tell you that well I admire you for
coming on Piers Morgan uncensored as I
did with Tyson always will always have a
fury on here you can tell Mr Paul uh
that we're looking forward to seeing him
coming on as well see how he gets on
for sure listen make him make all the
best of it Mr Jay parks in four weeks
she boxing career is completely over
because it never started in the first
place well go get him Tommy go do it for
Britain Tommy knock him out good to talk